[Musik]
seit jeher interessiert die menschen
sich für die sterne und planeten und es
wird unheimlich viel geld ausgegeben
dass wir die auch besser kennenlernen
man hat den mond mit einer genauigkeit
von etwa sieben meter kartiert den mars
mit 20 metern genauigkeit und selbst die
venus 7 schwefelsäure wolken bedeckt ist
kennen wir mit einer auflösung von 100
meter genau
die auflösung mit der 80 90 der tiefsee
460 des eigenen plan ist gedeckt hat
jetzt die bewegt sich bei etwa fünf
kilometern auflösung
man hat bei der suche nach bin immer
noch verschollenen flugzeug menschen die
allein 770 berge gefunden die 2000 meter
hoch sind in der tiefsee von dem vorher
noch niemals geahnt hat
[Musik]
und da ich keinen einfluss darauf habe
dass die welt in der geld in die hand
nimmt um vielleicht die mars mission
nicht durchzuführen und stattdessen die
eigene tiefe zu erkunden muss man halt
daran arbeiten dass die tiefsee
erkundung billiger sind deshalb hat sich
das team vom frauenhofer institut bei
max preis beworben und hat es bis in das
finale geschafft
7 millionen dollar sind zu gewinnen
dafür müssen aber auch anspruchsvolle
aufgaben erfüllt werden
ein autonomes unterwasserfahrzeug aus
den zwei bis 4000 meter tiefe eine
detailgetreue 3d karte erstellen in 24
stunden eine fläche von der grösse
frankfurt zudem werden fotos gefordert
von objekten relativ sehen sehr starke
konkurrenten müssen sicherlich die
japaner liegt vielleicht auch daran dass
japan natürlich noch ein engel und
funktionären hat als deutschland aber
auch vor allem daran dass sowohl
deutschland als auch japan sich beide
als ingenieur nationen sehen und es ist
eigentlich schon eine schande für beide
länder ist dass es seit 1994 die prices
kippten den besondere technische
innovationen
herausgefordert werden und keines der
beiden länder hat jemals bis jetzt
einige preise gewonnen
deswegen sind wir beide natürlich
besonders motiviert die beiden teams was
wir im wettbewerb gelernt haben gerade
auch bei der suche nach sponsoren dass
der namensgeber und hauptsponsor des
preisgeldes die firma shell was sich
manche firmen auch gesagt haben also
zwischen als sponsor eines projektes bei
denen es schnell auch gleichzeitig der
name spender ist damit wollen wir
irgendwie nichts zu tun haben und da ich
es auch nicht verhindern kann dass die
in der tiefsee unterwegs sind da auch
andere firmen vor brasilien angola immer
mehr in die tiefe gehen habe ich keine
probleme damit dass wir auch für diese
firmen der technologie bereitstellen die
es ihnen ermöglicht wird ihre
arbeitsprozesse sicherer und auch um
welt sicherer zu machen
es gibt eben nicht viele stellen auf der
welt wo man die technologie sehr nah an
die bedingung des wettbewerbs testen
kann
und das heißt man kann eigentlich von
land aus gar nicht direkt unmittelbar in
die tiefsee so wird der wettbewerb
verlangt
es gibt ein paar ausnahmen wenn man von
den kanaren aus kann man direkt ins
kanadische becken was eben bis 5000 6000
meter tief ist oder eben man kann hier
zwischen peloponnes und cäcilien gibt es
auch der sogenannte calypso tief ein
stück meeresgrund was 5500 meter tiefes
an der tiefsten stelle und deswegen
fanden wir sehr spannend hier testen zu
können
[Musik]
ich denke dass wir gute chancen haben
weil wir einfach ein paar
alleinstellungsmerkmale haben paar für
viele ideen
wir sind die einzigen die wirklich einen
robusten weg haben wie man die
unterwasserfahrzeuge nach der mission
wieder einfangen und zurück bringen kann
das spart eine menge batterieleistung
und sorgt dafür dass wir einfach mehr
unter wasser fahren können
wir sind die einzigen mehrere
oberflächen fahrzeuge verwenden auch das
macht uns schneller und vor allem
ermöglicht es uns eine
positioniergenauigkeit von 60
zentimetern während die große zweifel
habe dass die anderen teams realistisch
die fünf meter genau ich keinen
erreichen die eingefordert sind
jeder zeit über wurden zusammen dazu
müssen also 235 60 meter und bis jetzt
hier und ich würde jetzt quasi hier in
dem bereich würdigen testen wollte wir
machen das jetzt nicht fliegen 25 metern
genau ich würde sagen du nix dabei 14
meter oder sowas und ich werde genau an
ich werde ich werde darin eine autorin
die forscher wollen testen ob die
tiefste drohne schafft immer den
gleichen abstand zum meeresboden zu
halten ein entscheidendes kriterium für
das finale
doch zuerst muss die drohne wissen wo
sie sich befindet damit sie sich autonom
unter wasser bewegen kann
denn dort gibt es später kein gps-signal
werden den startpunkt soll die drohne
heute von einem ganz normalen smartphone
erhalten
in ufernähe hatte da schon geklappt
im quark oder butter und unser teuerste
einheit ist es ein gerät was die
geschwindigkeit über grund ist und diese
einheit ist eben ganz zentral wichtig
damit das gerät überhaupt funktionieren
kann überweisen des landes gesperrt wird
halt wie sieht's aus
es war echt das war weiter verhärtet
er ist zum beispiel hat das einfach
nicht geschafft sich zu emotionalisieren
also die anfangs koordinator des braucht
losfahren wie konnte es nicht ermittelt
am ende komme aber die werte nicht so
weit weg werden angenommen
es ist einfach so dass dem installiert
man wartet zehn minuten darauf ob sich
endlich initialisiert passiert nicht am
start investiert neuwahl denkt etwas
passiert wieder nichts
also weil verschwimmt jetzt frei im
wasser das handy habe ich ihn getroffen
so kann selbst von einer position aus
losfahren und 30 jahren
dies wäre es so einfach alles auf anhieb
funktionieren würde
der brauch zurück
und wieder hat das was gestern noch mal
gemacht haben nach der revitalisierung
jahrhundert ok verstand erfahrungen
zurückblicken haben und dann muss man
wieder unverrichteter dinge zurück
fahren an land das gerät aufschrauben
die daten herunter ziehen sich die
logfiles anschauen und studieren und
welt sind und sagen was es eigentlich
ist der kunde und da merkt man plötzlich
das gerät konnte die beiden datenquellen
nichts zusammenfinden dann findet man
erlöse und programmierte gestern hat
unsere programmierer bis nachts um elf
dagesessen und an diesen tagen wo alles
schief geht denkt man sich meine güte
sind jetzt nur fünf testtage noch übrig
und wir müssen auch dieses programm
schaffen und wir wollen ja gern noch
kapieren und auch noch diese daten und
man weiß ja auch nicht wie lange es
dauern wird so ein fehler zu finden ich
drehe ich gerade jetzt heute ist es
immer noch realistischer zeit gegangen
jetzt drücken wir mal die daumen dass es
heute besser wird und dass wir heute mit
günstigen karten
und jetzt wo wir etwas noch mal soll das
enden hier an bord das gab an scheint
ein problem zwischen seite drei sensoren
in unserem fahrzeug drin
und weil beide gleichzeitig angeschaltet
waren gab es einen konflikt jetzt
starten wir die nacheinander und dann
sollte alles funktionieren im finale
werden sie mit fünf tief sie drohen
unterwegs sein und für jedes gibt es
auch ein eigenes oberflächen fahrzeuge
katamarane die sich auch boote liefen
sollen hier eingebaut ist auch ein
autopilot um mehr den wortes weiter zu
steuern
das heißt wir geben dem fahrzeug
eigentlich nur einen wegpunkt vor zudem
erfahren soll dorthin manövrieren tut es
dann selber die oberflächen fahrzeuge
pink ständig ihre positionen etc drohen
und erzeugen so ein eigenes akustisches
gps system
nur eine drohne ist mit vier kameras
ausgestattet mit der 3d aufnahmen
gemacht werden können dafür muss sich
bis auf fünf meter der meeresoberfläche
nähern anderen bleiben in sicherem
abstand und erfasst mit sonargeräten die
umgebung
daraus soll dann eine karte vom
meeresboden entstehen grundsätzlich hat
er wurde besitzt schon initialisiert es
noch ein bisschen baden wird es nochmal
genauer und danke macht endlich loslegen
[Musik]
der plan ist jetzt in einer konstanten
höhe über grund zu fahren hier das war
so jetzt circa 20 meter tief deswegen
war der wahrscheinlich in einer höhe von
zehn metern konstante bank und und ziel
ist jetzt auch wenn sich das höhenprofil
von kunden ändert dass das fahrzeug
trotzdem immer den gleichen abstand
gewonnen weil das dann später wichtig in
die karten aufzunehmen dass mir jemand
in höhe von 80 metern über grund
einhalten
[Musik]
aber ich möchte jetzt natürlich weil
folgen
na dann um dich drum herum machen
systematik platz kann sie sich
ausdrucken
heute bin ich auf jeden fall zufrieden
heute hat das alles was gestern nicht
funktioniert hat ganz gut geklappt
nachts hat er erreicht hat auch
programmiert all die sachen wieder ein
statist entscheiden zu ihren zu haben
und also wer war es halt noch nicht
perfekt aber wir kommen voran
und wenn man das die nächsten tage so
fortsetzen dann klappt das gut aber das
ist natürlich kann es immer um seiner
schlecht vorherzusehen